안녕하세요. 시두회어입니다. 어느덧
2025년도 3분기에 다달았습니다.
저는 올해 아직은만으로 29이에요.
제 20대는 제 욕심만큼 많은 걸
이루진 못했어요. 하지만 확실한 건
반초해 봤을 때 많이 성장하고 또
변화한 시기였습니다.
직업적으로도 큰 변화를 겪었고 성격도
정말 정말 많이 바뀌었고 또 많은
취향이 피고졌습니다.
전자의 두 개를 다루긴 좀 웃낄 것
같고 오늘은 제 취향에 대해서 얘기해
보고자 합니다. 주변에 어떤 사람을
두고 있느냐에 따라서 삶의 방향이
바뀌듯이 내가 갖는 취향이 나라는
존재를 구성하는 것에서 굉장히 큰
부분을 차지한다고 생각해요. 올해
저는 제 인상이 어떻게 보이고 또
어떻게 보여지고 싶은지에 대해 관심이
생기면서 안경에 자연슬의 몸을 더
기울이게 됐습니다. 안경을 통해서 제
총체적인 인상을 실험해 보기도 했는데
제 취향 중 첫 번째로 올해 제가
구매한 안경을 먼저 몇 가지 보여
드릴게요.
제가 상반기에 안경들을 몇 개 샀고
작년부터 사실은 좀 안경들을 야금야금
모았어요. 제가 상반기에 산 것 중에
좀 마음에 드는 거는 이렇게 두
개입니다. 하나가이
마수나가라는 곳의 안경이고요.
하나는이
백산쿠산의
안경입니다. 하나씩 소개를 해
드릴게요. 일단은이 마수나가는 요렇게
생긴 메탈 안경입니다.
제가 메탈 안경이 하나도 없었어요.
지금까지 안경을 산 것들이 다
아세테이트나 셀룰로이드 소재인데
그러다 보니까 좀 가볍게 내가 노트북
같은 그런 화면을 보는 업무를 하거나
할 때 오랫동안 쓸 수 있는 그런
안경을 찾다 보니까이 메탈 안경을
구매하게 됐고요. 이거는 그 한남동에
있는 오르오르에서 구매를 하게
됐습니다. 제가이 마수나가라는
브랜드에 대해서 잘 알진 못해요.
이게 일본 브랜드고 여기 써 있다시피
1905년도에 시작했다라는 것만
알고요.
다만 이건 조금 찾아보니까 제가
구매한 모델이 코드 애라는 모델인데이
코드 라인들이 되게 유명하더라고요.
마스나가에서. 특히나이 코드 F는 어
나중에 찾아보니까 그 오징어 게임
시즌 1에서 박혜수 씨가
썼던 모델로 유명하더라고요. 그래서
쓰면은 이런 느낌입니다.
약간 지적인 느낌.
제 입으로 말하기 좀 그러지만 아무튼
좀 샤프한 느낌을 주는 그런
안경이라고 저는 생각을 하고요.
그러다 보니까 이런 캐주얼한 옷보다는
셔츠나 니트 같이 어느 정도 그래도
갇혀 입은 상태에서 이걸 썼을 때 좀
더 그 느낌이 합치한다고 저는 생각을
합니다. 그래서 어 사무실을 갈 때나
이렇게 잘 쓰고 있고 너무 가벼워서
굉장히 편하더라고요. 다만 제가
아세테이트나 셀룰로이드 같은 뿔
안경, 흔히 말해서 뿔 안경들을 어
주로 쓰던 사람이다 보니까 이런 메탈
안경을 썼을 때 좀 쓰고 벗을 때
제가 주위를 잘 안 기울이면은 잘
휘더라고요. 그래서 구매하고 나서
한두 달 있다가 다시 오르오르 가서
피팅을 하기도 했었는데 원래 어 저
같이 뿌텔 위주로 쓰던 분들이 이런
메탈을 사신다면 한번음 주의
기울이셔도 좋을 것 같습니다. 두
번째는이 백산 안경 하쿠산의
안경인데요. 요렇게 생긴 냅니다.
얘는 모델 이름이 정확히 기억이 안
나요. 제가 찾으면은 아래든 위에든
뛰어 놓겠습니다.음
음, 일단 이거는 가로 스킬 그
백산에서 샀고요. 한번 써 볼게요.
좀
독특한데 이런 좀 느낌입니다. 제가
이걸 구매하게 된 이유는 위아래가
짧은 뿔트를 사고 싶었어요. 좀 어디
일본 영화에서 봤었나? 그래 가지고
그걸 엄청 찾아다니다가
그 와중에 백산이라는 브랜드도 좀
경험을 해 보고 싶은 찰라에이 안경을
보고 구매를 하게 됐고요. 사실은
제가 사고 싶은 그런 위아래가 짧은
직사각형의 안경의 형태는 솔직하게
말해서 아니긴 합니다. 왜냐하면
여기가 약간 그 캐다이처럼 좀 이렇게
뻗어 있다고 해야 될까요? 그래가지고
그렇진 않지만 뭐랄까요? 좀 날카로워
보인다고 해야 될까요? 그래 가지고
어 이런 이미지를
가진 안경을 내가 구매한 적이
없으니까 얘도 한번 써 보자라고 해서
구매를 하게 됐고요. 실제로 이곳
저곳의 옷들에 매칭을 해 보니까 얘는
뭐 그런 셔츠류도 굉장히 잘
어울리겠으나 제가 지금 이렇게 입은
거 같이 캐주얼한 복장이나 좀
스트릿하게 편하게 입은 옷들이랑도
굉장히 잘 붙더라고요. 그래 가지고
어 이런 백산 안경에 그리고 이런
얇은 안경도 한번 고려해 보시면 좋을
거 같습니다.
물론 이거는 좀 주변에서 안
어울린다는 얘기도 잘 듣긴 하는데
둘중에선 전 이거 더 자주 쓰긴
합니다. 편해서요.
안경에이어서 현재 저와 제 취향을
가장 잘 표현하는 옷의 분류를 보여
드리겠습니다. 저는 정말 다양한
복식을 좋아하지만 그중 제게 있어
가장 굵은 갈래가 무엇인지를 생각해
봤을 때 아무래도 현재로서는
빈티지스러운 옷들인 것 같아요.
나온지 오래된 디자인의 제품이나 복각
제품들이 입었을 때 그 몸에 닿는
느낌이 더 자연스러워서 그런지 오해
붙더게 됐습니다.
처음 보여 드릴 제품은 라프시몬스의
2002 어트민터 리덕스 버전의 반팔
스웨트 셔츠입니다. 이건 제가 몇 년
전에 갖고 있다가 떠나보내고 이번에
다시 구매하게 된 제품이에요. 그
당시엔이 옷을 만편이 못 입게 써서
판매했었습니다.
라프시몬스라는 브랜드를 좋아하고 또
너무나 동경하지만 가격이 비싸서 잘
활용하지를 못하겠더라고요.
떠나보내고 계속 아름거렸는데이
제품에 아는 분들은 아시겠지만 이게
리덕스 에디션임에도 불구하고 매물이
정말 없습니다.
그러던 나중에 집 코 앞에서 여러
셀러분들이 참여하는 플리마켓에 최근에
가게 됐습니다. 정말 우연찮해요.
가프라는 가구샵겸 카페인데 가오폰
기간 동안 플리마켓을 진행하면서 여러
제품들을 판매하고 있더라고요. 빈티지
리바이스부터 뭐 보테가 베네타 니들스
그리고 직접 제작하신 제품들도 열어
있어서 보는 재미가 굉장히
있었습니다. 그런데 저는 딱이
라프시머스 제품에 꽂혀 버렸어요.
나중에 알게 된 거지만 이게 가프의
사장님이 내놓은 제품이었는데 제가
이걸 구매한다고 하니까 약간
좌절하시더라고요.
제가 잘 입기로 약속했습니다.이
라포시몬스의 리덕스 시리즈는
2021년에 출시했는데요. 가장
회자되는 라프시몬스의 컬렉션 중
하나인 2002 어트민터 버지니아
크리퍼를 브랜드에서 다시 복각해서
내놓은 시리즈입니다. 저는 그중에서이
제품이 원래부터 제일 마음에
들었어요. 첫 번째는 그래도 가장
접근성이 좋은 가격대 라프시몬스의
제품이라는 점이었고요. 둘째로는 제가
이런 반팔 맨투맨 형태에 빈티지한
옷을 계속 찾고 있었기 때문입니다.
물론 전형적인 그 시오리 잡힌 반팔
맨투맨는 아니긴 합니다. 셋째로 제가
정말 좋아하는 오역 씨가 예전에 그
뮤비 촬영 때인가 입으셨던 걸
봤었는데 그 느낌이 되게 강하게 제게
각인이 됐었어요. 그래서 그때 이후
아 무조건 난 이걸 갖긴 해야겠다
마음을 먹었었습니다.이 제품은 여러
개의 바지와 붙여 봤을 때 웬만한
종류랑 다 잘 맞더라고요. 뭐
중청이나 생지대님과도 잘 어울리고
이렇게 제가 입은 좀 물진 검정색의
바지화도 잘 붙습니다. 디테일을 조금
보면 앞뒤로는이 시즌의 제목이었던
버지니아 크리퍼스 그 쿨이 그려져
있어요. 곳곳에 조금씩이 구멍이 뚫린
빈티지한 디테일이 있고요. 안에는
살짝의 기모가 깔려 있습니다.
그런데이 옷에 모르는 분들한테는 뭐
그냥 나그랑 반팔티일 뿐입니다.
솔직하게. 하지만 제 개인의 만족으로
산 옷이니까 저는 마음에 듭니다.
이제 다시 안 팔 겁니다.
두 번째는 여러 차례 제가 소개해
드렸던 타이가 타크아시의 EOSS
106 네로우 카라셔츠입니다. 두
가지 색상으로 나왔는데이 제품은
인디고 샴브레이라는 컬러예요. 제가
지난 2월 달에 혼자 교토에 갔을 때
구매했던 제품인데 이건 소개를 따로
안 드렸었더라고요.
제가 타이가 타카이라는 브랜드를
그리고이 제품을 좋아하는 이유는
옛것의 미감을 살리되 본인들의 감각을
적당한 선에서 넣기 때문입니다.이
제품을 예로 설명드리면 106 셔츠는
본래 있던 104 셔츠에 없는 카라를
상상해서 구현한 제품입니다.
타이가타카시의 104 셔츠가 뭐냐면
1910년대 뉴욕의 셔츠를 본따 만든
제품인데요. 그 당시에는 세탁이 더
어렵고 빳빳한 카라가 더 격식 있는
스타일로 여겨졌기 때문에 카라가 없는
셔츠를 하나 사고 탈부착 가능한 긴만
교체하면서 입었다고 합니다. 그래서
밴드 카라를 가진 104 셔츠가
나오게 된 것이고 106 셔츠는
여기에 카라가 붙었다면 어떤
모습이었을까 해서 차에 만들어진
셔츠인 거죠.
비단 스토리만 괜찮은게 아니라 제품만
보더라도 이건 정말 예쁩니다. 보시면
단순히 선만 세로로 내려오는
스트라이프 셔츠가 아니고요. 인디고
원사와 유황 염색된 검색 원사 그리고
노란색 원사를 넣어서 가까이서 보든
멀리서 보든 개성 있는 패턴을
보여주는 제품입니다.
그리고 타가타카시를 좋아하는 또 다른
이유는 개인적으로 사고 후회하는
제품이 정말 거의 없어요. 뭐
가디건이든 바지든 데님이든 그리고이
셔츠든 제 옷장 속 수많은 옷들
사이에서 각각 1군 역할을 제대로 해
주고 있습니다.
교토에 타이가 타카시 매장에서 구매할
때 사이즈가이 가장 큰 것밖에 안
남아 있어서 크게 입을 수밖에 없는
상황인데요. 넣어 입지 못하는게
한편으로 조금 아쉽긴 합니다. 그래도
다행히도 뺏서 입어도 글이 어색하진
않아서 단품으로 입거나 가을 겨울에는
스트라이프 패턴이 살짝씩 보이게
레이어링하기에도 좋습니다. 확실히
색감의 바탕이 인디고라서 청바지랑
궁합이 정말 잘 맞더라고요.이
제품은 주로 데님과 특히 타이가
타카시의 대님과 이렇게 자주
입습니다.
마지막으로 소개해 드릴의 저를 표현할
수 있는 옷의 브랜드는 바로 투빌더스
하우스입니다. 이건 제가 몇 달 전에
알게 된 국내 브랜드예요. 그 당시에
제가 어디 바에서 술을 마시고
있었는데 사장님이 입으신 베스트가
너무 독특하면서도 예뻤습니다. 약간
그 포라든 슈메이커스 같은 아티잔한
느낌이 나는 옷이었어요.
좀 술도 들어갔겠다. 나갈 때
사장님한테 어디 건지 여쭤 보니까이
투빌더스 하우스라는 브랜드의
제품이었습니다.
브랜드를 찾아보니까 기본적으로 미리
제작해서 판매하는 제품도 있긴 하지만
직접 상담을 통해서 맞춤 제작을 해
주는 곳이었어요. 인스타그램을 통해서
날짜를 잡고 또 작업 공간겸 쇼룸에
들렀습니다.
어 한시간에 넘게 대표님이랑 대화를
하면서 샘플도 입어보고 제가 원하는
형태의 자켓을 만들어 나가는 과정을
거쳤어요.
여러 소재를 이렇게 쫙 펼쳐 보면서
자켓의 겉감은 어떤 것으로 할지, 팔
안쪽은 어떤 소재로 할지, 양쪽을
다른 소재로 할지, 단추는 어떤
사이즈에 어떤 소재로 몇 개를
할지까지 정말 디테일하게
잡아줬습니다. 제가이 자켓을 40만
원 정도에 구매했는데 그런 긴 과정에
대한 결과물이라는 걸 감안하면 저는
괜찮은 가격이라고 생각합니다.이
이 브랜드 대표님 말로는 사람들이
이런 오래 입을 수 있는 옷을
포라든처럼 비싼 브랜드에서 구매하지
않 그래도 제품의 가치를 느낄 수
있을 정도로 가격을 책정했다고
합니다. 제가 구매한이 자켓에 대해서
설명을 하면 브랜드에서 가장
시그니처격의 실로지인 투버튼
재켓입니다. 겉감은 일본산 면사의
머싱으로 가공 처리가 들어가 있어요.
안감 또한 일본산 면사로 광택감이
없는 두툼한 하얀색입니다. 그래서이
소매를 접어 올렸을 때 안감이
보이는게 꽤나 매력 있는 제품입니다.
착용감은 제 몸에 맞춰서 그런지
굉장히 편해요.이 포라든 슈메이커스의
재켓은 입어 봤을 때 아무리 너무
좁아서 좀 불편하기도 한데이 제품은
그에 비해서 아무래도 넉넉하고 가슴
둘레도 적당한 편입니다. 날씨가요
더워서 몇 번 입진 못했지만 오랫동안
좀 툭툭 걸쳐 입을 것 같은 느낌이
드는 옷이에요. 제가 지금 입은
것처럼 안에 셔츠를 입었을 때 특히
예쁜 거 같고 그냥 무난한 뭐 라운드
넥과 함께 입어도 이질감이 없을
듯합니다. 다만 워싱에 들어간 검정색
자켓시라서 그런지 좀 워싱에 들어간
그런 빈티지한 하이와 특히 잘 붙는
것 같습니다.
국내에서 이렇게 강단 있게 철학을
갖고 밀고 나가는 브랜드가 있다는게
참 좋고 제가 이걸 알게 되어서 너무
기쁘더라고요. 한번 시간 나실 때
인스타그램에 보시고 또 작업실에
방문해 보시면 정말 좋은 경험이 될
것 같습니다.
옷은이 정도로 마무리하고 저를
구성하는 다른 취향의 영역 하나
정도만 더 공유해 보려 합니다. 저는
늘 강조하듯이 마음의 방이 많은
사람이고 정말 이것저것을 다
좋아합니다. 스포츠도 웬만한 건 다
좋아하고 영화도 공포부터 잔잔한
것까지 다양한 장례를 즐기고요.
저의 여러 취향 중 말씀드릴 건
그래도 제게 가장 큰 비중을 차지하는
음악입니다.
저는 음악 듣는 걸 매우매우 좋아하고
장르 가리지 않고 웬만해서 다
들어요. 힙합, 발라드, 클래식,
R&B, 재즈 전부 다 좋아합니다.
딱 M만 빼고요. 작년부터 최근까지
여러 장례 중에서이 밴드 음악의
비중이 꽤나 저에게는 높아진
편인데요. 최근들어 콘서트를 이곳저곳
다녀와 보니까 밴드 음악을 라이브로
들었을 때 그기 소리와 보컬이
어울러질 때 오는 전율이 오래 기억에
남더라고요.
밴드는 뭐 다들 좋아하시는 밴드들
좋아합니다. 최근 갔던 혁서트 정말의
충격적이었고요. 올해 초에 검정치마도
빼놓을 수 없고요. 꼭 죽기 전에
콘서트에가 보고 싶은 더 일구치료도
있고 이제 곧 볼 예정인 오아시스 참
좋아합니다.이 오아시스가 내안을 하긴
하고 제가 또 내안 공연 예매도 해
놓긴 했어요. 근데 저는 좀 더 일찍
좀 더 근본인 곳에서 보고 싶어서
영국으로 갑니다. 엠블리 스타디움에서
이제 한 몇 주 후에 볼 예정인데요.
보에미안 랩소리 영화 속 그 퀸의
공연처럼 한 10만 명 가까이
들어가지 않을까 싶은데 뭐 또 하나의
역사 속에 작은 점이 될 수 있을 것
같아서 너무너무 기대하고 있습니다.이
위에 말씀드린 밴드들을 포함해서 제가
실제로 자주 듣는 노래를 좀
모아봤는데요. 제 노래 취향 중에 좀
백색소 같은 잔잔한 곡 위주로 넣어
봤습니다.이 이 설명란에 넣어
놨으니까 드라이브 하거나 밤에 쉴 때
들으시는 걸 추천드립니다.
제 영상을 보는 분들의 연령대 분석을
보니까 대부분이 제 나이
또래시더라고요.
저는 앞자리 삶이 코앞이긴 하지만
아직 참 철게도 해 보고 싶은 것도
가보고 싶은 것도 많습니다. 솔직하게
아직 나이가 많은 것도 아니긴
하니까요. 아무튼 남은 2025년도
그리고 앞으로도 제 취향을 열심히
키우고 또 채워 나가서 공유드릴 수
있도록 해보겠습니다.
오늘 제 이야기는 여기까지입니다.
감사합니다.